Beyond this light, there's a world different from here, Grimoire. There's a
world where the mirage you lost gathers. The mirage we lost,
yeah, so what are we going to do? We're leaving for Grimoire.
[Music] It does
n't matter whether we remember the memories or not.  It
means that you might be able to learn about the past you lost.
Kahaihi Haki
Mirage Let's have a contest to see who can defeat Mirage first Kaoh
Hati It's been a long
time since the two of us are Mirage users, so if we
use Mirage to proceed.  It's okay, let's
work together and move forward.
[Music] Are
you the king of the Bahamut army?
You should call yourself the Warrior of Light instead.